yeah welcome to blitz video five minute
game and it's dee Ford III reversed
Stonewall yeah blacks got done quite a
number of good setups I like this one
the idea too is to play e5 and black
here already am has got some some
problems with the center he's got a hard
time to to keep his center intact here
yeah just um a weak poor nalanda form
wondering how to how to use this best I
can play Bishop a6 and attacking this
rook yeah how to get pressure on this
pawn night somewhere could play 95 but
doesn't really help I also wouldn't mind
really to to exchange those pawns see
against deep on just to to open up the
possession the position even more
we'd be 60 Michael Knight to be three
okay many as nyad's an idea to try to go
to d3 he wants to play a 95 though hmm
interesting yeah maybe I should have
paid more attention to this idea looks a
bit awkward that hear that he is coming
to to see five ads not the end of the
world but suddenly I'm nothing nothing
great for black yeah it's all nice with
the two bishops but maybe I'm I had
something better Queen d2 it's not clear
what this is doing probably nothing much
I'll try to get the night on e six
controlling the c5 square and maybe I'm
getting more pressure on the deep on he
can go on at c5 p.m. okay I don't want
to exchange
hmm well this is a temple ride & now
let's let's go here activating the
bishop I'm not sure what what he's doing
on the kingside maybe there's a 95 or
something but I can take and defaults
hanging also so I'm just attacking at
the moment b3 and deform can I don't see
his some his big idea ok this one the
n95 of course is a move Adam I can take
here now 96b should be six is just next
to peace and d4 now is hanging with with
check so I don't see a move really
Bishop g7 I can tape with the bishop and
it's a not much happening Bishop f8 yeah
but before I saying with checks up with
Queens am also getting exchanged
yeah this is actually a very good setup
for black against the the worst
Stonewall if white goes for the
Stonewall attack here you are you can of
course play d5 at c5 but this d6 and c5
idea with this push it's very strong
here here black already a.m. it's got an
advantage white needs to play em some
something else well maybe in advantages
it's an exaggeration maybe white can
somehow on keepin equal position but
it's tricky thing here he's already
struggling to here for example I I just
retook here within a typical blitz move
here I think I can take on e3 rc3 let's
see yeah computer d state t3 and black
wins yeah I didn't now I see if we just
need one second once in a while just
take the end and this is great of course
what should should i do can just
recapture and then I grab the end and
it's basically done his position is full
of holes I've got two bishops yeah the
soul wallet tech is not so great William
and it's especially problematic if black
as seen here hasn't played d5 on f4 d5
let's say first moves and I think it's
something that is easily playable yeah
thanks for watching